Ted Malick was an informal adviser to
the Donald Trump campaign in March he
says he was detained at an airport by
investigators for Robert Muller who took
away his cell phone and asked about his
ties to Roger stone among other things
he is also the author of the book the
plot to destroy Trump how the deep state
fabricated the Russian dossier to
subvert the president Ted Malick joins
us tonight Ted thank you for coming on
when you say you were detained tell us
this I mean that's kind of a remarkable
story tell us the circumstances of this
well especially for a Yale Oxford Hanley
Business School professor to be stopped
at an airport taken into a room and
asked questions by the FBI and having
their phone then under a warrant seized
but I write about this in the book as a
postscript and my lawyers tell me not to
confirm or deny very much about this
because I'm still actively participating
in this conversation I don't understand
why would that put you in legal peril if
you believe the government overstepped
and detained you at this is it Logan
Airport in Boston right you're flying in
from abroad correct they pull you aside
take your cell phone and ask you
questions you have no lawyer president
is that correct during this conversation
none at all
okay so so how I mean why would you be
in jeopardy by exercising your First
Amendment right to explain the truth
well I have explained it as a postscript
to the book and actually detailed it and
I'm told that the FBI is not all that
happy about that fact so therefore you
know I'm not really at liberty to say a
whole lot more about where this stands
at present right give us a sense that
when you when you sat down you you had
no lawyer it's generally not advised to
talk to the FBI
without a lawyer did they just grab you
as you got off the plane and what did
you say to them when they did yeah well
they they had me wait for about 20
minutes as I say and then divided me for
my wife and then
searched my belongings and took me to
you know a separate building to
introduce me to two FBI agents who asked
me a series of questions actually was
quite chitchat II for about 20 minutes
as a fan of the Philadelphia Eagles they
asked me of what I thought of their
victory at the Superbowl mm-hmm that's
what they said to Mike Flynn too during
his chitchat II Congress so they had a
warrant for all of this I assume is that
right
correct okay what did they ask you well
as I as I said in the in the PostScript
you know there are very few substantive
questions some about individuals you
know what my relationship was the
campaign they seem to know all the
answer to the questions
did you consider saying buzz off I'm not
going to answer your questions well I
think had they gotten and any more
aggressive than you know in fact that
would have been the case but they were
fairly benign I'm a patriotic American
I'm you know a cold warrior I worked in
the State Department I was top American
in the UN in Geneva Switzerland for four
years at the end of the Cold War you
know I'm certainly willing to cooperate
in any inquiry I I don't think I have
much to add why do you think they wanted
to talk to you
well my publisher thinks they had pre
read my book on the plot to destroy the
president which is in fact about the
conspiracy the the first in in American
history since 1783 in the Newburgh
conspiracy that tried to overthrow a
sitting president of the United States
hmm why did they ask you about Roger
stone I I have no idea I'm gonna met
Roger stone three times he did write the
foreword to my new book because we have
the same publisher he gave an address at
Oxford University about eight or ten
weeks ago and it was a pretty compelling
story about what happened in the 2016
election
and we had a transcribed I had attended
that lecture and we used it as the
forward to the book so maybe they read
more into that than is the case what
they do to your phone you said they had
a they had a warrant for your phone yes
they confiscated my phone and I'm told
it's been returned to me and I should be
receiving it any day they took your
phone away how long have they had it
well since that day which was before
Easter I'd be pretty annoyed Ted thank
you for joining us I appreciate it
good to be with you Tucker thanks